another thing that could be a sweetener
and this leads to our next topic if mark
murphy were to say oh by the way we're
also trading for julio jones that could
be an enticement to get aaron rodgers to
play one more year how do we think the
julio jones situation is going to play
out peter and i assume neither of us
believe he's going to end up in green
bay where do you think he's going to be
in 2021
well mike for a long time i felt like
new england was the best option for
julio jones just because of bill
belichick's
uh
you know work over the years with
veterans and having them come in having
them fit in
okay
but two things happened after i wrote
that uh last week after i said i thought
new england was was a you know had a
good shot
um number one
remember
when they
uh dealt a fourth-round pick for randy
moss in 2007. they basically told him
hey listen you know we can't pay you a
lot of money it's like whenever they get
the old veterans who really want to get
rescued from somewhere corey dylan randy
moss like you know you basically tell
them hey look here's your contract
here's what you're gonna have to make to
come here and i doubt sincerely that the
patriots would agree
to pay julio jones with his recent
injury history with the fact that he
doesn't practice very much
38 million dollars over three years so i
now think that a team like
tennessee
would have a very good shot at him it
makes all the sense in the world their
receiving core is down they've watched
the indianapolis colts in player
acquisition and drafting and at the
quarterback position position get really
good
so i i think it would serve the titans
to in their best interest
to figure out a way to work the cap this
year they don't have the money this year
they'd have to you know fool around with
the contract to do it but the next two
years they're in good cap shape and they
could afford julio jones so i think
tennessee is the best option for him
you mentioned the patriots not being
willing to pay julio jones 38 million
over three years it works out to about
12.7 million per year
i i believe julio jones doesn't want 38
million over three years i think he
wants more than three you believe he
wants more years he's either gonna ask
for more money on the way in the door or
or
he's gonna play his ass off in 2021 and
want more money out and make you give
him that contract next year
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do at that point and and that that's the
reality whether it's julio jones aaron
rodgers russell wilson
the things that
fractured the relationship with the
current team
can fracture the relationship with the
new team and one of the things that
fractured the relationship between the
falcons and julio jones was his push
three years ago to get more money once
once matt ryan got to 30 million a year
and julio was making 15 he said what the
bleep is wrong with this picture and
that he got to 22. and now you know you
don't think that you're on a deal worth
22 million per year when you got three
years left at 38 that works out to 12.75
especially if you get to a new team so
whoever trades for him is gonna have to
factor that in as well and peter that's
why i think the trade hasn't happened
the window's wide open now trade hasn't
happened because number one they can't
get to where they want to be and arthur
blank i'm told is driving that bus he
can't understand why he can't get more
than a second round pick when he got a
second round pick for mohamed saw and
gave up a second round pick for hayden
hurst how can i how can i not get more
than a second round pick for julio jones
theory i had yesterday let me let me get
your thoughts on whether you like this
because i thought at one point they
would have to keep julio jones because
maybe when we get into the season and a
team emerges as a super bowl contender
and they know they're going to be or at
least assume they're going to be
drafting late in round one that may be
when a team says fine we'll give you a
first round pick for this guy because
we're going all in and we're going to
try to win the super bowl
what if
the falcons and julio jones agree
don't come to camp
don't report
stay in shape
but stay away
and at some point before the deadline
the tuesday after week eight we will
trade you that's the quid pro quo i
think there's a chance that's the only
way they're going to get to a first
round pick
well i think the issue with that is if
you tell a guy don't come to camp
you don't have the ability really right
now
i don't think mike you might know this i
don't think you have the ability to say
don't come to camp because then he'd
still he's under contract he'd still be
fined two million dollars total
aggregate for missing camp
so you'd have to find some way to make
him whole for that wouldn't you
you just don't put him on the reserve
did not report list you'd have to carry
him on your 90-man roster and then the
challenge becomes
where do you pigeonhole him
when the regular season begins hey what
if you just put him on active physically
unable to perform or something like that
i mean look they can if they're
committed to this
there's a way they could pull it off
rich mckay knows the league well enough
to know how to pull it off and not have
anyone ask any delicate questions about
julio jones status but but you're right
and and this is a fairly new twist in
the cba
if you don't report it's mandatory that
that money is paid it's mandatory that
you can no longer say okay fine you know
we love you and we understand why you
held out we're not going to collect the
2 million in fines for staying away for
all the camps so that that is a wrinkle
in this but i think rich mckay would
know how to figure it out either way
peter i
i think they're not going to get that
first round pick between now and
training camp i just don't think
somebody's going to wake up and say okay
fine i don't see it either first round i
don't see it either
and mike somebody's got a blank that you
talk about the risk the risk of the the
scenario that you talk about is you know
so
i know one team that's very interested
in julio jones
and this is a team that values
practice
and it values a guy's being able to be
on the field for practice and you hear
all these stories of julio jones only
practiced a handful of times last year
and
however many times he practiced he
certainly doesn't practice every day or
nearly every day
so i think one of the issues one of the
dangers is
after as physical a career as he has had
and now he's 32 years old
you know the question is do you have a
guarantee that he's going to play the
first seven games of this year and be
healthy as a moose coming into the week
of the trading deadline you know that's
a that's a risky road to take if you're
the atlanta falcons and quite honestly i
would much rather have
the uh the boyle lanced
and the trade done right now for a solid
two without contributing anything to the
acquiring team with the 38 million
dollars
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports